bonjour eric zemmour bonjour selon vous
la polémique autour du traitement à la
chloroquine du professeur à ault dépasse
largement le cadre médical pourquoi
c'est depuis le début c'est très
intéressant de dire depuis le début est
de plus en plus ça devient une histoire
politique une bataille politique au sens
noble et une bataille mondiale et en
particulier française puisque évidemment
le professeur out incarne c'est cet
antagonisme français entre paris et la
province entre l'establishment et les
rebelles et même sur le plan mondial
c'est un peu les grands groupes
pharmaceutiques mondiaux contrôler le
petit village gaulois qui ne veut pas
céder à l'envahisseur vous voyez il ya
toute cette toute cette fantasmagorie
autour de raout comment ce professeur de
médecine didier rahout est il devenu une
figure du populisme
moi je dirais que c'est laid comme
d'habitude les élites qui appellent
leurs adversaires populiste quand on ne
veut pas se coucher devant la doxa
dominante on est populiste
sarah août il défend un traitement alors
il défend une manne modèle qui est le
modèle médical on traite et puis depuis
le début il dit que ce que le film en
général est une folie que c'est un skate
c'est que ces issues du moyen-âge depuis
le début il dit qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
faire ça et depuis le début dit que son
traitement à la chloroquine avec un
antibiotique
doit être donnée au début de l'infection
on vient tous des grands spécialistes
everett est passionnant dans cette
épidémie on apprend - progresse mais et
vous avez vu d'ailleurs il ya une étude
la notice publiée par la revue dans
cette revue scientifique ou combien
respectable qui dit en gros que la
chloroquine le traitement que leurs
habiletés qu'une catastrophe et que
elles tuent des gens etc
sauf que quand on voit dans le détail on
s'aperçoit que les gens qui ont fait
l'étude ont donné le traitement du
professeur out mais à la fin alors que
les gens sont déjà très mal en point
donc évidemment c'est le contraire du
protocole défini par le professeur ne
peut pas juger ça et d'ailleurs out
répond que c'est je crois j'ai plus il a
une formule terrible que c'est une étude
de foot est une foutaise foireuse
d'autres foireuse voilà merci d'autres
d'autres médecins le défendre ça devient
et et en même temps le ministre de la
santé qui ne le porte pas dans son coeur
olivier ferrand accès immédiatement
la décision du haut conseil de la santé
publique qui a interdit le cas proscrit
donc le traitement de du professeur
raoul
oui on est dans une bataille mais
homérique etc etc etc etc est vraiment
alors évidemment on va accuser le
professeur out de populisme est il et
pas populiste du tout il défend voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est le pop qui se
reconnaît en lui et c'est les élites qui
l'attaquent en tout cas l'establishment
politico médicale vous dites que cette
querelle autour du professeur raoul fait
écho à des imaginaires ancestraux mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par là je
vous ai dit
paris contre province d'abord
le marseillais contre l'establishment
parisien puis on a vu que ça se
mondialise c'est très étonnant parce que
parce que je vous dis on devient tous
des grands spécialistes ont j'ai lu
c'est très intéressant
le rédacteur en chef de la revue lens
est un emblème ce norton droit qui
explique que les études publiées par sa
revue sont de plus en plus plus en plus
sujette à caution
parce que des grands groupes mondiaux se
dissimulant derrière des soi-disant
institut de recherche indépendant
développe ses études pour vendre entre
guillemets leurs médicaments et donc ils
mettaient en garde contre la revue lens
est qu'il dirige lui-même
donc voyez juste au moment où cette
revue la démolir à ou donc si vous
voulez là on à l'imaginaire des grands
groupes mondiaux et qui veulent imposer
leurs médicaments on apprend que le
roupe gilead à des antiviraux beaucoup
plus cher que la pauvre chloroquine
discours hamad saoud qui vaut trois
francs six sous
comme on disait dans mon enfance et on a
aussi des grands groupes qui veulent
développer le vaccin qui qu'ils vendront
à sept milliards d'humains et donc ça va
rapporter beaucoup d'argent donc on a
ces enjeux-là financiers colossaux
on a le côté je vous dis establishment
parisien contre le plouc entre
guillemets marseillais le pauvre symbole
n'est pas du tout a plus que vous avez
compris ce que je veux dire à fait dans
les imaginaires et voilà on en est là
quoi
et vous alors eric zemmour vous êtes pro
ou anti raul tu
moi je vais vous dire je suis plutôt pro
encore une fois je suis pas du tout
médecin je suis pas du tout scientifique
et je veux vraiment là mais ce qui me
plaît d'abord ce qui m'a plu on lui ces
deux choses d'abord un le fait qu'il ait
dit que ce confinement général était une
absurdité et sage il est tout de suite
pensé sans être médecin brice et de
l'extérieur et deux ils essayent de
soigner moi c'est ça qui me plaît chez
nous c'est un médecin trois voiliers il
attend pas d études randomisées comme on
dit gigantesque et cetera
pour comparer le blanc du noir etc
il essaye de trouver des traitements
humblement qui soigne je dis pas que ça
marche j'y connais rien encore une fois
je pas du tout faire le savant que je ne
suis pas mais sa démarche me plaît voyez
voilà merci à eric zemmour